qu'est-ce qu'on connaîtra la liste des
candidats investis c'est votre charge en
comptabilité adou en respectant les
critères un pas de casier judiciaire
2 1 la parité la parité pour les
circonscriptions gagnables pour les
femmes
2 plus de 50% de la société civile notre
responsabilité c'est de fournir au
conseil d'administration présidé par
emmanuel macron la totalité des
candidats je pense dans les jours qui
viennent
soyez encore dans les jours qui viennent
nous sommes en train de terminer à
cordes et à vent avant le second tour en
cinq ans je pense que demain nous aurons
à peu près mais ils vont terminer demain
vous avez terminé la quasi totalité
nous sommes à plus de 500
circonscription qui ont été étudiées
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui à vincent
sur 577
on est pressé il ya quelques portes qui
restent ouvertes ou qui sont sous verte
maintenant pour quelques-uns et
notamment manuel valls combien de temps
est-ce que ces portes vont rester
ouvertes
la force des manuels mais cros et sa
cohérence et qu'il n'y ait aucune
ambiguïté et l'on voit bien qu'il est
toute une série de jeu politique
consiste à dire je suis macro
compatibles et témoin des candidats
relativement aux faibles etc
nous nous disons votre choix c'est votre
choix nous le respectons et vous en
assumer les conséquences
nous nous proposons un projet
présidentiel incarné par un président si
vous décidez de le soutenir
vous adhérez à en marche vous vous
inscrivez à la préfecture sur
l'investiture en marche et les choses
sont très claires si vous décidez de
rester dans vos appareils politiques et
bien à ce moment là nous constatons ce
choix et nous mettrons un candidat sans
rival veut être candidat en marche il
faut qu'ils passent par la procédure
normale avec une lettre il vous envoie
un cv aux candidatures reçues son cv
auprès d'elle à toulouse a pas écrit
encore avec une lettre de motivation
vous avez créé encore pas encore encore
toute candidature doit être analysée
pour être analysés doit passer par le
site en marche mais